t-bob info is a platform that covers
many different areas of analysis many
different data types and this is what
you see when you first log on to the T
bio info platform what I want to start
showing you is how you can look at the
different interface in user workflow so
that you understand the functionality of
the platform so first of all each one of
these has a little overlay that explains
the type of data the different data
types have different challenges in our
platform would probably be most
interesting for integration as well as
basic processing so if we take a look at
RNA seek which is under NGS we can see
that the whole screen is going to be
divided into two sections the top
section that is user input of data type
so we can take model of genome that's
one of the genomes that's uploaded on
the system single and repair end fast
queue and then here we can use human as
an example I'll just create one file per
group and then this bottom part really
allows the user to start creating a
pipeline so I can click buttons and I
can see that there's a limited selection
to minimize the user err of inputs and
outputs which is normally a big
challenge in these much more flexible
interfaces also each section is covered
by a logical group and this logical
group has an explanation and also each
button has an explanation we can read
more about the type of algorithm and see
some of the inputs that you have here on
the right side so that is how you create
the pipeline and by clicking the button
you now see that it's connected I can
now go on and click another button and
so forth up until I hit the end button
the end button is not going to be
available if you haven't reached stage
where
that makes sense you can also see all of
the different pipelines that are being
run by this user so you can see the idea
of the pipeline the name of the pipeline
the status when it was created we can
edit the name we can delete it you can
also see more information that gives you
some technical information and also
download the report that will be a PDF
report of this pipeline going back to
the areas of analysis you can either use
this screen that gives you the overview
of all of the options or you can
navigate through this menu that only
shows you the currently available
sections one of the sections of interest
is biology that is unique to our system
because it works with the Searcy data
type and you can watch a video right
here this method was created at UCSF in
Stanford and funded by DARPA and allows
you to see much more precise mutation
variants in RNA viruses so as you use
the RNA virus the sequencing information
you can also then integrate it with
regular NGS data and also some data from
proteomics and even take it to the
talking of molecules the talking of
molecules is also a proprietary section
on our platform and this section allows
you to either search for a specific
molecule based on an example molecule or
you can agree databases clustered
databases that show a number of
molecules with similar physical chemical
properties so similar pipelines are
available for many different types of
analysis for example we have a sulphate
metagenomics assembly non supervised
analysis of non-coding DNA and RNA and
also a section for machine learning
that has some typical machine learning
algorithms here they allowed to do basic
things like BCA factor analysis as well
as more advanced things like by
association and by clustering we also
have tutorials these tutorials take
example projects and focus on some
specific data set and allow the user to
use the system while following somebody
else's example they mostly have a video
text and a downloadable PDF and our goal
with this section is to turn it into an
area for education and also if we go
back to the areas of analysis and for
example RNA seek we have this guided
tour button over here if you get stuck
anywhere will help you keep on going and
see what's happening yeah that's pretty
much it for a demo account you can
contact us at info at PI biotech com